a source has come to me and suggested
that Amazon have a big plan a plan that
if true
will divide Stargate fans
and actually maybe even upset a few of
you
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV
movie channel
[Music]
so on a couple of lives recently I've
been talking about my idea about how to
conclude Stargate Universe I suggested
we should do it with an animated movie a
couple of days ago I released a video
talking about how I had this whole plan
for Stargate for when the franchise
return and that did include a Stargate
animated movie I basically suggested
that because Amazon are doing animated
movies with Warner Brothers animation
and Warner Brothers animation have just
done the Babylon 5 animated movie so
that inspired my cogs and I thought well
would that make sense
I then got a message from a source I
haven't spoken to in nearly a year and
the message basically said How did you
know that
I responded with I didn't know that I
did not know that SGU is going to be an
animated movie I was just talking out
loud thinking
and they said well you might be closer
to the truth than you think
and obviously I then had to follow up
with a few questions before we get into
it I have to say this is firmly in the
rumor category I have tried to speak to
other sources that I speak to that are
in and around MGM and none of them know
anything about this
this Source again I haven't spoken to
for about a year I have confirmed that
they do work at MGM they still work at
MGM they spoke to me back then because
they were very unhappy about the Amazon
sale but they were always kind of
nervous about talking to a YouTuber and
you know they cut ties for quite a long
time
what they have actually said though
which is again firmly in the rumor
category like I'm going to put a big
sign up going
um
is that
not only is an SGU movie planned
it's already in production they're
already making it
now I'm going to come back to that point
in a little while because if true that's
quite extraordinary
so first of all the divisiveness why do
I think this will actually upset as many
fans as it looks site SGU is one of
those shows that is either loved I mean
like adored like some people think it's
genuinely the best of all the Stargates
or not so much people think it's a
little boring I'm in that camp I have to
admit I don't love it and they you know
don't really care about Stargate
Universe I would argue however though
that most Gators are irritated by the
way SGU ended that it's just been left
in limbo and would like a conclusion to
it
my argument was that I don't think there
are enough fans to Warrant a new series
and a movie or anything like that
but maybe there is enough interest to
get the SGU animated movie because it
would cost much much less to produce
so it's logical
is it possible though the Amazon
Executives have been thinking the same
way as me but thought about it six
months ago
well there have been a few rumors over
the last 12 months that all of a sudden
would make maybe a little bit more sense
if we consider this SGU possibility to
be true first of all we heard a rumor
eight or nine months ago now I think and
something like that that Robert Carlisle
had actually been approached about doing
something for MGM related to Stargate so
we got very excited said well does that
mean we are actually getting a Stargate
SGU conclusion Brad Wright always said
we would
and if they were actually approaching
him were those plans further on than we
realized now since then we've realized
that actually no it looks like they
aren't going for a movie could Robert
Carlisle appear in that it seemed
unlikely but what if they approached
Robert Carlisle about doing the voice of
rush for the animated movie a project
that then he potentially actually did
the work for anything up to six months
ago
now
I am completely just the spitball in
there that is just me thinking out loud
but is it possible
Maybe
another rumor that we heard a lot about
was that Amazon were talking to Warner
Brothers about doing star game we
genuinely believe that Bad Robot pitched
at least twice for the Stargate
franchise and they are obviously
currently in an exclusive deal with
Warner Brothers Warner Brothers are
looking to produce more things with
other Studios the Creed series was
actually done recently in Partnership
between Warner Brothers and MGM so
there's already that working
relationship Amazon are doing the Lord
of the Rings animated movie in
partnership with Warner Brothers
animation
so is it possible actually that those
rumors were nothing to do with sort of
the Prime the main Stargate franchise
but actually were more to do with an
animated SGU movie
that's where the rumors came from that's
why we have constantly heard Warner
Brothers names connected to Stargate but
really it wasn't Warner Brothers it was
Warner Brothers animation we should have
been looking at again I'm speculating
but maybe I can't help but think as well
though that this is just a way to
actually restart the franchise in a
positive way that would really make
sense to a lot of fans
you tie off all those loose strings you
have like a full circle you know you
begin where you ended you get to
actually have a satisfying end to SGU
that will excite fans and get us keen
and excited about the new Stargate
franchise
to me it seems a bit of a no-brainer to
Amazon that they might at least consider
this
but is it possible that they've actually
already done it is it possible that this
is maybe being animated right now
so if we go by the Robert Carlisle
possible rumor
now the rumor I heard basically was the
rubber color bin approached to do
something the David blue hadn't been I
should add to this David blue who played
Eli but Amazon didn't want to approach
him about it now I don't know why that
is I have heard a few rumors about
possibly why but I don't want to go into
him I actually really respect David blue
I think he's a brilliant actor I love
him to death I follow him on Twitter and
I think he's great and I don't want to
get into rumors that are quite negative
and because as well I don't know if
they're true or not so let's just leave
it but
that was the rumor that they hadn't
approached him so if Robert Carlisle had
maybe done the voice for this SGU
animated movie
um that maybe ran along the lines of the
comic books they did something like that
he'd done that maybe three four months
ago something like that and this was now
being animated is that the normal way to
do this well well yes they tend to do
storyboarding
a script obviously they get an idea what
the movie is going to look like they do
some preliminary pre-production they
then do the voice acting they then do
the animation because then the animators
can use the inflections of the voice of
the actor Etc and it changes the
animation so what they don't want to do
is animate something and have the actor
just trying to like follow the lines
they want to actually bring a little bit
of the actor into the actual animation
if they can
so he could have done that three or four
months ago but now we've got all the
strikes so would that be a problem well
no the animators aren't on strike
they're still working so again this
could be something that actually Amazon
are able to do look they want to do and
they want to announce lots of things
RoboCop Stargate etc etc etc but they
can't because of the strikes
but what they can do
is an animated movie
so maybe they are
that open up another interesting
possibility though what if as soon as
the strikes end they are then able to
announce the new Stargate franchise and
oh by the way in a couple of months the
animated movie comes out
but could they actually keep an animated
movie like that secret this long
they did it with the Babylon 5 Road home
movie we knew nothing about that until
it was complete it was done it was in
the can it was ready to be released JMS
announced it J Michael zaginski the
creator of Babylon 5 announced it on
Twitter
nobody knew nobody had that
they were able to keep it really really
secret because it's a bunch of animators
locked in a room and the actors only
come in and then again get locked in a
room for a couple of days it's very very
difficult unless you've got an Insider
actually at the Animation Studios to get
that information out there are no big
sets being built that you know you get
lots of leagues from there aren't lots
and lots of people involved in it to
again for somebody to leak it so it's
very possible that this SG new movie
actually has already had the voices done
and is currently being animated maybe
this wasn't Amazon's plan all along the
source actually did say to me look the
strikes and obviously they knew the
strikes were coming for a few months
before but the strikes have changed
Amazon's plans
this was not how they wanted to do this
but it's the best they can do with what
they've got
now if that is true and I'm putting a
big if underlined in bold if that is
true
then actually it's very logical and it
does kind of make sense
now I have to reiterate this is one
source that has given me this
information I do not know how they know
it I do not know details this is
basically look two emails that I got and
they were both quite brief the source
does not want to go into any more
details they are actually quite afraid
of their about losing their job and they
never really like talking to me in the
first place
but this really is a fascinating piece
of information I would like to publicly
thank them for sharing it with me I
really do like the fact that I have a
few sources particularly from MGM that
do talk to me this all started with one
person at MGM sending me a message about
a video actually that I did that was
incorrect they were then amazing at sort
of introducing me to other sources the
sources that actually gave me this
information has never really given me
stuff like this before but they were
really instrumental and again
introducing me to others I've been able
to build up a little bit of trust over
the last 18 months to two years and
these sources know that they can tell me
this stuff and I will keep their
identities a secret and I will only
share what they tell me I can
I have to admit it's very annoying there
is one piece of information particularly
about Stargate right now that I know
that I can't share and I know that's
teasing but it's driving me crazy that I
can't tell you
let's hope I can at some point soon
I would love to know the guys though
what you actually think about this is it
possible for one and How likely is it if
you think it is possible I'm going
this is maybe one in three I would give
this a one in three chance of being
actually true
so possible good possibility but
unlikely is the way I feel about it
um but I'd love to know what sort of
chance you would give it
and if it is true do you want to see it
so when I first heard about this rumor
and I wondered whether it's possible I
put a poll on the channel and I
basically said if the only way Amazon
MGM were willing to include SGU is with
an animated movie would you buy the
Blu-ray and by that I mean Blu-ray
stream it whatever it will pay you to
watch it
38 of you said yes sign me up 25 of your
quarter said no I won't watch animation
and 36 percent of you said yeah I'll
watch it but I'll wait till it's
somewhere free you know basically on
somewhere I already pay so you know
Netflix or something
that had 1.7 000 votes so 1700 of you
voted so I am doing a little bit of
promotional research for Amazon three
quarters of your customers actually
would watch an animated SGU movie
okay a big chunk of them won't pay for
it but
if they did this
actually people would get excited about
it
a quarter of you wouldn't
that's a big percentage as well
but hey Amazon if you have done this I
actually applaud you for doing something
quite Brave
and if you haven't then you're an idiot
you should have been
but never mind if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification you can follow all
these links that have been scrolling
down at the bottom particularly go to
patreon.com Sidetrack that really
supports the channel
as always though please stay safe and
I'll see you next time
foreign
[Music]